do you feel confident
why
what are you saying
does my silence
indicate confidence probably not hey
it's betsy i'm jasmine i'm katie today i
will be competing against my co-workers
to see who can create the best original
dish using thanksgiving leftovers in
under 60 minutes the leftovers include
turkey mashed potatoes gravy cranberry
sauce stuffing roasted vegetables green
beans and pumpkin pie we're also allowed
to add whatever additional ingredients
we want and then our co-worker kelly
will judge our dishes based on how many
of the leftovers we use if we finish
within the 60 minute time frame our
dishes presentation and finally taste
i'm definitely very nervous you know i'm
a very competitive person i have a lot
of competitive energy but my confidence
level is
low i feel like i have a delicious plan
but i i'm scared of betsy and jasmine
for sure they're fierce competitors
today i am going to be making a
thanksgiving leftovers charcuterie board
i'm gonna have four homemade components
a pumpkin pie truffle prosciutto wrapped
stuffing bites a roasted veggie dip then
some crostinis with some smoked salmon
topped with some fancy piped mashed
potatoes garnished with a little bit of
fresh dill i can get that done in 60
minutes right three
two
one
go
i'm gonna start by making pumpkin pie
truffles first things first we are going
to put this slice of pumpkin pie into
this dish here and we're gonna mash it
up with a fork okay that looks good i'm
gonna loosely start to create some balls
i love dessert so i knew that i had to
have at least one sweet thing on the
platter
i'm moving on to our prosciutto wrapped
stuffing bites i am now gonna take our
leftover stuffing and form it into more
balls next i'm going to take our
beautiful prosciutto and wrap it around
the outside trying to make this look as
graceful as possible which is why we
have toothpicks to kind of help secure
it on there wow that looks good i'm
intimidated i think i'm more intimidated
by katie and jasmine than i am kelly
please be good
we are now gonna move on to our roasted
veggie dip we're gonna place our roasted
veggies into a food processor along with
some cream cheese because cream cheese
makes everything better and now i'm
gonna add in two garlic cloves
i'm gonna scrape down the sides here a
little bit a little pepper
and a little salt and i'm also gonna add
in a little bit of olive oil to loosen
it up a little bit
oh there we go
we're getting there
it does smell good but does a good smell
mean good taste
it could use some onion or some chives
so i'll put in a few
our dip is done you have 40 minutes
remaining oh okay so i've got some
crackers here i'm now going to top them
off with some smoked salmon so this
smoked salmon is very thick i feel like
it's very hard for me to like make it
look pretty but fear not we are going to
actually top the smoked salmon with our
mashed potatoes i'm gonna transfer our
mashed potatoes to a piping bag fitted
with a piping tip and we're gonna pipe
them on top oh gosh it's like spaghetti
i don't have a plan b oh gosh
i now have a new piping tip that is a
slightly more open here we go
[Music]
a little better for sure
that's fine
come on
like there's pieces of potato getting
stuck in the piping tip
i think i'm gonna need a plan c
plan c
same piping tip this time however we
added some milk to our mashed potatoes
to help loosen them up a little bit all
right let's give it a go let's give it a
go okay guys this is much better a
little runny but i'll take it we did it
now i'm gonna place some fresh dill on
top and voila our smoked salmon mashed
potato crackers are finished
we are on our last step we are going to
now coat our pumpkin pie pops into some
melted dark chocolate i also have some
freshly ground graham crackers to top
them off
our chocolate pumpkin pie pops are done
one of the reasons why i chose a
charcuterie board is because you kind of
go through all of these steps to make a
thanksgiving feast so i really wanted to
kind of deconstruct that and make it
kind of easier approachable and
shareable so by looking at my
charcuterie board i think i've included
every single thanksgiving leftover we
have our roasted veggies our mashed
potatoes green beans cranberry sauce
turkey stuffing pumpkin pie and we even
have our gravy one thing's for sure this
charcuterie board has something for
everyone all right i'm done you have one
minute and 31 seconds oh
yes
yeah
i'm gonna use all the ingredients to
make a croquette flight i'll start with
the vegetable appetizer croquette move
to the turkey entree croquette and then
finally a dessert croquette with the
pumpkin pie i went with the croquette
flight because i'm also a producer on
bring me and our biggest hits are always
the flights never made a curl cap before
so we're off to a great start your time
starts
now
ah okay okay okay start with some oil
got some chopped green beans gonna go
ahead and throw the roasted vegetables
in there as well and i'm adding these
onions i'm just gonna stir fry these
vegetables for a little bit until
they're heated through all right they're
almost heated through so i'm gonna
sprinkle a bit of garlic salt don't want
kelly eating anything unseasoned some
pepper
oh i'm still shaking i'm nervous you
know the feeling of when you make
something very special and then you give
it to someone and they don't like it
there's always that paranoia
okay this looks pretty good i'm gonna
turn off the heat we're gonna transfer
these to our bowl with mashed potatoes
which are leftovers mix that up for the
sake of more flavor i'm just going to
add a splash of gravy it's so chunky
this looks good so i'm going to move on
to dredging i'm flouring my hands to
prevent it from sticking so i can roll
this into a nice ball shape or a
flattened oval
dip it in the flour
no why did i do that i should have made
the wet batter first okay i'm so dumb so
i'm gonna add about like a tablespoon of
cupi
yes kewpie is superior it is a little
sweeter a little tangier i'm gonna add
some water
let's dip that in there
you said presentation matters huh asking
for a friend asking for katie
okay so now that it is in this flat oval
shape i'm gonna put it into the air
fryer and then gonna spray it
okay that's gonna go for eight minutes
so while that's going we can make our
next croquette
why
what are you saying
okay we have a working air fryer now
i'm gonna let that go for eight minutes
and i'll flip it halfway through but for
now let's move on to the entree turkey
croquette i have some olive oil heated
up here and we're gonna start by
caramelizing our onions how much time do
i got left you have 40 minutes i think
we're on a good track i'm probably gonna
let them caramelize until they're just
before medium brown okay not bad i'm
just gonna stop caramelizing now i'm
gonna remove the extra oil you know what
fried onions are delicious so this is
this will be a treat so i'm gonna mix
stuffing
it's extremely dry just a little bit of
gravy
some garlic salt and some black pepper
i got the mashed potato mixture that i
made from earlier just gonna add it in
here because it is extremely dry and it
needs to hold together okay this looks
good let's get to dredging
throw it into the fryer and move on to
the next one
we have 20 minutes on oh we got what
okay we gotta move on to the next one
like now okay we're on our last
croquette i'm doing the dessert
croquette using pumpkin pie i'm gonna
first carve out some filling the crust
on the bottom is too wet so i am going
to take the side of the crust and
crumble it in here this doesn't look
like enough so i might have to use the
wet crust anyway all right i'm just
going to throw it all in it all tastes
the same in the end you know okay it's
getting to the point in the competition
where i'm like i have so little time and
i need to do everything 10 minutes ago
that doesn't look like it
i'm just gonna throw a little more in i
have used the pumpkin pie leftovers
let's add in the marshmallows
just going to fold that together when
it's really wet it doesn't hold its
shape so i'm going to add some
cornstarch as a thickener
i'm going to add a little bit more
marshmallows i need it to stay together
while it's cooking because if it melts
all together into the fryer i'm out okay
i'm gonna add the granola
oh it's kind of thick all right whatever
we don't have time to crush it so let's
get to dredging we're not gonna use the
same egg as last time because i had mayo
gonna add a splash of milk though
okay that looks good 15 minutes ah
so much pressure this is a pretty good
shape i'm actually really surprised it's
holding it together
oh my gosh
these granolas are humongous the pie
crust is sticking much better than the
granola but i actually think this might
work okay the one thing is now the size
is much bigger than the other croquettes
but a big dessert is good i think and
everyone has a second stomach for
dessert
okay eight minutes on the clock i'm
shaking my clock is running down but
when that comes out we're just going to
go ahead and plate it everything is
plated and
i'm done you have five minutes and 21
seconds left yes okay finished in time i
used all the ingredients and i finished
within 60 minutes it's hard to say how
confident i am because i haven't seen
betsy and katie's dish but i would say
i'm walking out feeling better than i
did walking in i think it looks pretty
decent but now it's up to kelly to
decide whether or not she likes it and
if it looks good enough
so here's my plan i'm going to be using
everything but the green beans to make a
delicious trio of raviolis i'm not using
green beans because i don't like them
and i forgot that they were there so
they didn't they weren't in my plan your
time starts now okay
okay so right now i'm gonna be making my
ravioli dough first and this is just
some double o flour so i'm gonna add my
eggs into my well of flour and then i'm
going to add a little bit of olive oil
and then i'll just take a fork and beat
these eggs in the center and we don't
want our well to break and my walls
broke my walls broke and it's fine you
know this happens i'm just gonna kind of
gently pull this in on itself here so
i'm gonna bring this now together with
my hands and then i am gonna let the
machine do the work for me because i
have too much stuff to do so i'm gonna
put this in my mixer with a dough hook
all right i'm gonna let this go for five
minutes or at least till it's nice and
smooth and when you press the dough it
springs back
it's gonna walk away
all right our dough looks done so i'm
just gonna wrap this in plastic wrap and
i'm going to let this rest for about 20
to 25 minutes while i make the fillings
so my first filling is kind of like the
whole shebang a little bit i'm gonna add
some of that leftover turkey that's i've
shredded it so that it's gonna combine
really nicely and you get a little
turkey in every bite i'm gonna add some
cranberry which could be a mistake i've
never tried this before but i think the
tartness is going to go really well in
here and then i'm going to add some
fresh thyme i will do a little bit of
gruyere cheese i'm going to add one egg
this is going to help bind all of this
together and then i'm just gonna start
mixing this together i don't know dare i
add more cranberry is kelly does kelly
hate cranberry i'm gonna bank on she
loves it and we're just gonna add a
little bit more
okay my turkey stuffing filling is done
and i am going to move on to my cheesy
potato filling this next filling i'm
kind of basing off like a pierogi
filling they usually like a cheese
potato filling so that's what i'm trying
to go for here i'm going to add a little
bit of gravy because like you know
mashed potatoes and gravy so i'm gonna
add in some parmesan because i like a
sharper cheese and then some cheddar
which is just kind of my classic cheesy
potato
oh i like it
i'm gonna add a little pepper
all right these are looking nice some
smooth mashed potatoes so these are done
i'm gonna move on to my last one which
is a sweet filling this next filling is
a pumpkin filling with some roasted
veggies what i'm gonna do is take some
of our leftover pumpkin pie i'm just
gonna use the filling we're gonna put
this into a food processor so i'm gonna
try to dull that sweetness by adding
some of these roasted carrots and sweet
potatoes and then i'm gonna add some
goat cheese it'll help bind this
together and kind of cut through all
that sweetness and then i'm going to add
in some fresh nutmeg because it just
smells like the holidays and it just has
a lot of flavor and then we'll add a
little bit of salt and some pepper
and i'm just going to add a little bit
of olive oil to help loosen it up
i'm going to actually add a little bit
of water the olive oil doesn't seem to
be enough and i don't want to like alter
the taste too much
that's looking good it smells like
pumpkin pie but let's see
if it still tastes like pumpkin pie
i think that's good all right well i
think i'm done with my filling so now i
just have to assemble my raviolis how
much time do i have left you have 32
minutes left we gotta get going we gotta
go so i have my ravioli dough here i am
gonna cut this guy into quarters i don't
want to be working with too much dough
at once for the guys i'm not using right
now i'm gonna cover in plastic so they
don't dry out and i probably don't need
all that dough but i made backup because
you know mistakes so for this first
section of dough i'm just going to
flatten it out i'm not going to put any
flour on this dough because it's pretty
dry dough already i will have her
sprinkle a little onto my pasta roller
and we'll get it going and we're just
gonna put our pasta through this machine
and then i'm gonna fold it like that and
it helps get a nice shape to it and
we're gonna run it through a few times
and you can just see it's getting longer
and longer every time we do it we're
gonna stop there
and i am gonna put some plastic over
that guy so it doesn't dry out i'm gonna
repeat those steps one more time all
right i'm gonna quickly assemble my
ravioli so i have my second sheet here
and i'm gonna gently brush that with
water i don't wanna get it soaking or
anything like that but this is gonna
help us seal it later usually you'd make
a small ravioli and you fold this in
half but i'm making giant ones so first
i'll put on my pumpkin pie filling
next i'm gonna put down some stuffing
and last i'm gonna add my cheesy potato
okay so before my
water dries i'm to place this other
sheet of pasta over it you want to
squeeze all around the base of your
ravioli trying to get out that air
because if you leave air it has a chance
of opening up while it's cooking and you
don't want that i'm going to cut this
middle guy out first so i'm going to use
a pasta cutter and i am going to do a
square for him 20 minute warning okay 20
minutes that's fine that's fine the
sauce is going to be fast let's do a
triangle for this guy which i'm just
going to go for it and then for our last
one feels like it's like grade school or
something because there's all these
really silly shapes great huge i'm gonna
go get some boiling water and we're
gonna make our sauce and we're almost
ready for plating so i've got my
raviolis cooking and boiling water
that's going to happen real fast so i'm
going to start to make our sauce i am
going to do a brown butter sage sauce
i'm going to cut the butter up into
pieces this way our butter just cooks
more evenly so you want to be constantly
stirring the butter and you can't really
not pay attention because it can go from
being brown to burned very quickly so
while this is going i'm gonna add in
some walnuts for texture and flavor and
then i'm gonna add some sage and these
are all gonna toast and fry in the
butter and just give us deliciousness
all right so i'm adding some salt you
can smell that sage and now you can see
we're getting those brown bits when you
drag the spoon you can kind of see those
in there
all right our pasta is ready to go
none of them broke apart so that's good
and a little pasta water in this is okay
these are giant i think i should do
making it big with alvin these are so
good
we're just gonna toss these in the sauce
gently just want to coat that and now
we're gonna plate these guys
ten minute warning okay if i can't plate
this in ten minutes i should be fired
and then i'm just gonna pour
some of these sauce over the top here
i'm gonna add a little bit of crushed
pepper on top and some parmesan stop the
time
all right you finished your dish with
seven minutes and 34 seconds
do i win i used all but one ingredient i
think it actually looks pretty great and
now the only thing left to do is have
kelly judge it hopefully not harshly
hey i'm kelly and i'm the lead culinary
producer here at tasty and i'm going to
judge each of these three dishes before
i try anything we have a few points to
calculate so based off the number of
leftovers they used betsy gets a seven
out of seven jasmine gets a seven out of
seven and katie gets a 6.5 out of seven
because she forgot about the green beans
so since they all finish cooking within
the 60 minutes they'll each get three
more points so now for presentation on a
scale of one to three i'm going to give
betsy a three because this is insane
jasmine a two and kadia three there's
nothing wrong with jasmine's but i just
think katie and betsy really blew it out
of the park jasmine's is beautiful but i
think it could have been displayed a
little bit different so last up is the
taste test the most important part i'm
gonna be ranking them one out of three
three being my favorite so betsy's i
just think it is so beautiful i can't
wait to try everything she did a really
good job visually
i know bessie was worried about that dip
but it is incredible
all right let's try jasmine's so a
little secret i hate cranberry sauce
it's my least favorite part of
thanksgiving
wow you can see the marshmallow like
melting in there
it tastes incredible this was a really
ingenious idea this is the cheese and
potato one
all right this is the turkey one that
she put extra cranberry sauce in so
let's see
the cranberry sauce actually balances
out the saltiness of the rest of the
dish it's really good
now that i've tried all three i think i
know which one's my favorite so let's go
tell them all right ladies you did a
great job everything tasted amazing but
there can only be one winner
the winner is
[Music]
katie
i loved yours because i felt like you
took it a step further you browned
butter you made the sage super crispy
and you made pasta like i wouldn't have
even tried to attempt that in 60 minutes
i was a little skeptical about that
cranberry sauce wait do you not like
cranberry i hate cranberry
but it actually went really well
together i'm so excited i won i never
win anything but this is so much fun
thank you guys for doing this with me
and thank you kelly for being our judge
let us know if there's any other
leftover challenges you guys want us to
try and until next time bye guys bye
oh yes
[Music]
you